at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also do personal
question now it is seen
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton books I've loved
on the Tim Ferriss show is exclusively
brought to you by audible there couldn't
be a better sponsor for this series my
dear listeners and readers I have used
audible for so many years as long as I
can remember I love it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet I listen when
I'm taking walks I listen while I'm
cooking I listen whenever I can and if
you're looking for a place to start
I can recommend three of my favorites
the first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca
if you want to hear my favorite letters
of all time touches on stoic philosophy
calmness under duress etc the next is
the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman GA IMA
n one of my favorites even if you're a
nonfiction purist this is the fiction
book that you need to listen to neo also
has perhaps the most calming voice of
all time in 3rd Gregg McEwan's
essentialism subtitle the disciplined
pursuit of less this is one of my
favorite books in the past few years
combines very well with the 80/20
principle but more inaudible every month
audible members get one credit for any
audiobook on the site plus a choice of
multiple audible originals from a
rotating selection they also get access
to daily news digests from the likes of
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
and The Washington Post as well as
guided meditation programs and here are
some other amazing audible features and
I use a bunch of these you can download
titles and listen offline anytime
anywhere
I use this feature even when I could get
access I'll put my phone on say airplane
mode because I want to get bothered with
notifications and I'm taking a walk to
clear my head and you can listen to you
titles offline in a case like that or on
a plane or whatever obviously I'm not
flying much these days the app is free
and can be installed on all smartphones
and tablets you can listen across
devices without losing your spot and
whisper sync is another feature I use
quite a lot I loved reading my Kindle in
bed for instance then picking up at the
same exact spot where I left off when I
go walking and listening the next day
Kindle and audio versions can be synched
up automatically it's just amazing and
if you can't decide what the Alyssa do
don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them for instance to binge
on a whole series if you like audible
offers just about everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a list comedy and audible
originals you won't find anywhere else
and right now audible is offering you
guys that's Tim Ferriss show listeners a
free audiobook with a 30 day trial
membership and again my list if you want
to check them out
the Tao of Seneca the graveyard book
essentialism those are just three
there's so many good ones out there just
go to audible.com slash Tim and browse
the unmatched selection of audio
programs then download your free title
and start listening it's that easy let's
check it out go to audible.com slash tim
or text tim t IM to 500 500 to get
started today
check it out audible.com slash tim hello
boys and girls ladies and germs this is
tim ferriss welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is
usually my job to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types startup founders investors chess
champions Olympic athletes you name it
to tease out that habits that you can
apply in your own lives this episode
however is an experiment and part of a
short-form series that I'm doing simply
called books I've loved I've invited
some amazing past guests close friends
and new faces to share their favorite
books describe their favorite books the
books that have influenced them changed
them transform them for the better and I
hope you pick up one or two new mentors
in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own
life I had a lot of fun putting this
together inviting these people to
participate and have learned so so much
myself I hope that is also the case for
you please enjoy my name is Maria Popova
and I am a reader and a writer and for
13 years now I've been writing about
what I read what I think about what I
aspire toward on a website called brain
pickings I also spent eight years on a
labor of love that became the book a
velocity of being letters your young
reader which is a collection of
Illustrated letters to kids about the
power and the joy of reading how it
shapes who we become with contributions
by a hundred and twenty one of the most
interesting people of our time Jane
Goodall yo-yo ma and Neil came in
Richard Branson and also a lovely letter
from Tim with all proceeds from the book
benefiting the New York Public Library
System and I wrote a very thick very
yellow book called figuring which looks
at our human search for truth for
meaning for self-actualization for love
through the lives of several historical
figures spanning four centuries
beginning with the astronomer you
is kepler who revolutionized our
understanding of the universe with his
laws of planetary motion and ending with
the marine biologist and author Rachel
Carson who catalyzed the modern
environmental movement and that is also
how I read and what I read across
disciplines across eras across
sensibilities and that is the lens with
which I've chosen the the three books
I'm about to recommend they're also
books wonderful in large part for being
underappreciated books of quiet
revolution that have kind of course
beneath the surface of mainstream
attention and awareness the first book
is a tiny tiny gem of a book called
letter from a hostage by Antoine de
saint-exupéry the author of the little
prince which is of course one of the
most beloved I hesitate to say
children's books of all time because I
consider it really a work of philosophy
and deep deep psychological insights in
fact I reread it about once a year every
year and each time I find in it new
revelations of meaning new existential
remedies really for whatever it is I'm
struggling with in my own life for that
particular moment
sonnig subaru was a commercial pilot
before world war ii and once the war
broke out he served as a pilot for the
French military running reconnaissance
missions at one point he became a
prisoner of war after his plane crashed
over the Sahara Desert led her to a
hostage is his slim memoir recounting
that experience reflecting on its deeper
significance an experience that informed
and inspired the little prince but also
opened up these enormous questions of
what does it mean to live what is the
wellspring of our humanity how do we how
do we keep our noblest impulses alive in
the midst of
death and destruction and divisive
naseeha etic writer and this is just an
incredibly soulful humanistic book but
also incredibly lucid and helpful
helpful in a very practical sense that
trickles down from the philosophical and
the poetic the the practical sense of
how do we live these human lives how do
we live meaningfully and honorably and
purposefully despite the foibles and the
imperfections of the world and end of
our own hearts the the second book is
one that shines a sidewise gleam on
perhaps the most elemental of these
questions it's called love and st.
Augustine by Hannah Arendt and it's an
improbable and and deeply insightful
inquiry into the life of the heart by
one of the most incisive intellects who
ever lived and and one of the greatest
political thinkers our civilization has
produced it is her first book length
manuscript and the last to be published
in English it was posthumously
discovered amongst her papers by two
women a political scientist and a
philosopher who were doing research on
her for half a century after I wrote
this asked her doctoral theses in
Germany in 1929 she obsessively revised
and annotated the manuscript and for the
remainder of her life she honed her core
philosophical ideas against Augustine's
whetstone contemplating the troublesome
disconnect between philosophy and
politics particularly moral philosophy
and politics as evidenced by the rise of
totalitarian regimes which of course she
later explored in her just just
shockingly relevant book the origins of
totalitarianism and all the while in
love and st. Augustine's
he contemplates the nature of love and
how to live with our fundamental fear of
its loss she was just a tiny passage
from it she writes fearlessness is what
love seeks such fearlessness exists only
in the complete calm that can no longer
be shaken by events expected of the
future hence the only valid tense is the
present the now it was from Augustine
that Iran borrowed the phrase Ahmad
Mundi love of the world which would
become a defining feature of her
philosophy in her her core political
concern which was why do we succumb to
and why do we normalize evil the
question at the heart of her now iconic
book the banality of evil
Arendt identified as the root of tyranny
the act of making other human beings
irrelevant again and again she returned
to Augustine for the antidote love my
final and crowning pick is a kind of
unifying force for the questions raised
by the other two books it's a book by
the astrophysicist Janna Levin who
became a real-life friend after I first
encountered her through her beautiful
writing and the book is called a madman
dreams of Turing machines and perhaps
it's best described as a mathematical
historical novel how's that for us B
specificity but but just aside any label
really only loosely captures this
uncommon ly original intellectually
storing soulful poetic book drawing on
the real lives of two great geniuses to
whom we owe much of what we take for
granted today including my ability to
record this and your ability to listen
to its digital echoes across the
space-time fabric of ones and zeros
the great computing pioneer Alan Turing
and the great mathematician logician
Kurt gödel it's a book that looks at
their lives to unpeel the core of their
genius and also of their tragedy and to
look at how the two intertwined to give
us these remarkable people of just
immense impact and out of their lives
arise these larger Universal questions
about the nature of genius the
relationship between our suffering and
our achievement and the search for truth
beyond logic the book belongs to that
very very rare species of incredibly
poetic books by working scientists by an
author who happens to be one of the
world's foremost probably the foremost
expert on black holes but is also a
writer of deeply poetic prose and and a
thinker of deeply poetic thoughts it's a
slim book and I read it long before I
knew Jenna in person and it really
shaped the way I think about what
literature can be it is extremely form
bending genre-bending there is no
analogue no book I can say it is like
and it has really informed the way I
think and I write and in a great sense
that I've only recognized in hindsight
it really informed how I wrote figuring
hello I'm Tyler Cowen I'm an economist
at George Mason University and the
Mercatus Center I'm a blogger at
marginal Revolution and the host of a
podcast called conversations with Tyler
people sometimes don't believe me when I
talk about how many books pass through
the house if I'm not traveling it's
quite ordinary if I go through five or
ten books a day and which parts for them
I've read you can debate maybe it washes
out to be reading two or three books a
day some good nights you get to read
five all books right but the important
thing is to be rude
listen with the books that are not good
just stop reading put him down usually
throw them away don't give them away you
could be doing harm to people if you
give them away and my philosophy of
reading is that no one reads quickly so
someone once asked me well how long did
it take you to read that book and I said
57 years I'm 57 years old so the way you
read well is just by reading a lot and
by reading a lot your whole life and
then when you go to read actual books
you're like I know that I know that I
know that and you keep on going and you
read much more quickly and that's really
the way to read a lot there are these
compounding returns to being obsessed
with reading and starting young and
never stopping sometimes authors just go
on and on with blather or with personal
detail that is no relevance to the
argument or they're just pages of
terminology and it's like well you might
still give the book a chance but you
start turning the pages more rapidly and
you're just waiting for some bit of meat
you're like out there desperate giving
the author still a chance and you at
some point you're like no sorry
zap throw it in the trash onto the next
one
most books are not half great and half
horrible and you should look at a few
different parts of the book but
especially these days and authors should
be able to signal by putting some good
stuff up front right because people are
less patient than they used to be a
nineteenth-century book you need to give
it more time it may not get good until
chapter 3 but these days my goodness you
can tell so much sometimes just from the
font of a book like there are books with
bad font management books and you're
like oh my god it's that font again and
you just throw it out you don't have to
read it at all a lot of books come to
the home so I get many review copies on
a weekday I'll probably average getting
5 to 10 review copies probably I'm
buying on average two books a day those
have a much higher chance there then
books people give me all sorts of things
so books from my library that I'm
rereading there's really just a heavy
flow and you have to deal with it
somehow the best reading is focused
reading when you're trying to solve some
kind of problem so if I'm doing one of
my own podcasts with a guest and then
I'll read or reread everything the guest
is written typically it's a reread
because I have on guests I like and if I
them I've already read a lot of their
stuff right so you're rereading with an
eye toward what is actually interesting
about this person and you learn much
more that way than if you just randomly
pick up books so I advocate reading
books and clusters the author can be the
clustering factor it can be the topic it
can be the historical period but you
really get into a person's mind if you
reread everything they've done within
the span of a few weeks or months and
then watch them on YouTube and just try
to think about and write out and out's
what am I going to ask them one of the
very best ways to read is to have your
own podcast you want to start with the
problem or question when you're reading
and again you want to read books
together in groups and you want one of
the early books to make the whole thing
real or emotionally vivid to you if you
travel to a place that will do it
automatically but if you're not
traveling you want the book to do it so
your early book choice is quite
important and then many areas so take
the case of ancient Egypt as you
mentioned I don't know what's the best
book on ancient Egypt but I know there's
enough uncertainty about what went on in
ancient Egypt that there's probably not
a clearly well-defined here's the best
book on ancient Egypt so you want to
read ten or twenty of them and do a kind
of cross-sectional mental econometrics
and see which pieces start fitting
together and take it from that so in so
many areas it's a mistake oh what's the
best book on X rather you're looking for
some kind of portfolio of books on X my
first recommendation would be fiction
reading fiction is important to
understand the cross-sectional variation
in humanity to understand how difficult
generalizations can be to just get a
sense of how social pieces fit together
and to get a sense of different
historical errors plus reading fiction
is often just plain flat-out fun so I
think my fiction read I found the most
rewarding was Marcel Proust remembrance
of things past which comes in multiple
volumes it's a very long read I'd say
about a third of it is quite boring but
the peaks are just amazing and it's also
hilarious and it's about how inner
monologues work and why expectation
matters
and what disappointment feels like and
what is jealousy like and what's it mean
to be a kind of total failure in a
social world or to climb and reach
higher levels of status so I think
that's just a thrilling remarkable set
of volumes some of the very best parts
came early so the first two volumes are
incredible the last volume is incredible
what comes in between is more uneven but
you always feel he's going to come back
to the main story lines you care about
and even the bad parts they're not that
bad but it could have been edited down a
bit right let's be honest the second
book I'll recommend is a book on a
management except it's not really books
about management at all it's something
else let me explain well I'm against
most books on management the worst way
to learn management is to read a book on
management I recommend to people read a
book on something you know about so if
you're a football fan I read about Vince
Lombardi or read Jerry Kramer's instant
replay my favorite book on management is
a book about the classic rock group The
Byrds Bui RDS it's by Johnny Rogan it's
called timeless flight it's hundreds of
pages about how the Byrds split up and
couldn't work together and it's
brilliant it helps you understand small
groups I work in small groups a lot I'm
not saying you should read that book you
need to know about the birds for the
book to make sense pick an area you know
really well and read a book about actual
substantive events that in no way has
management in the title and is not in
the management section of the bookshelf
and then maybe you'll start learning
something about management very often
the books that are vivid to me are books
I've read recently or in the last year
and a book I think it was very very
famous at its time one of the best
salaries of its century but people have
stopped reading it and that is Harriet
Beecher Stowe Uncle Tom's Cabin which is
a book about migration a book about
travel a book about race obviously a
book about slavery a book about America
in the middle of the nineteenth century
it has vivid characters the issue is
maybe for a while seemed obsolete but
they're highly highly relevant today it
just leads a kind of humanity on
virtually every page and communicates
what the suffering is like of being in a
tragic situation and how there are some
structural features of America that tend
to breed
kinds of tragedies slavery and in that
day often on migration issues today so I
would say go back and read it there's a
reason why it was one of the two or
three best-selling books of the 19th
century those people were not stupider
than we were it's a somewhat different
context it's a bit long but once you
pick it up you're immediately in the
book and the way you would be engrossed
in say a popular novel and indeed it was
a popular novel in its time I would say
if you're looking to read memoirs don't
necessarily follow other people's
recommendations focus on reading memoirs
and areas you know something about and
then just google to online lists what
are the best memoirs in that area and
read a bunch of those and then here's
the other next thing you should do every
area you don't give a damn about you
probably should read at least one book
in because the very best book in that
area is superb and you're not going to
know what it is
so if tennis is something you don't know
anything about well read Andre Agassi's
memoir that's a wonderful book you don't
have to know or care about tennis and
just go through other areas gardening
dogs turtles whatever find the best book
on dogs and read it and the less you
like dogs actually the better that book
is going to be because you are not sick
of the topic here's a book I read last
night it's by Scott H Young
it's called ultra learning the subtitle
is master hard skills outsmart the
competition and accelerate your career
I'm all for all those things how did I
get this book I met Scott I had lunch
with Scott he gave me a copy of his book
it's actually not a bad filter to read
the books of people you meet because
then getting to meet you is itself a
kind of filter and if they get through
that filter then maybe their book is
interesting too because you have
structures set up to match people to you
based on shared interests so I care a
great deal about the topic I had a lot
of fun with Scott and I learned Scott as
this guy who learned a whole bunch of
languages on his own in just a few
months time and he just kind of mastered
them and he teaches you with secrets on
how to learn things quickly and that's
been an obsession of mine since I was a
kid so this is a book very much after my
own heart if you're a knowledge worker
you want to be better earn more advance
your career you can't just sit back and
be complacent you need to be
thinking every day in a sense every
minute how am i training myself to get
better you're much more like an athlete
or a concert pianist or a chess player
than you might think
and the people who do really well
they're just always self-training so how
you should self train depends on your
job one way I self train is just by
doing like my own podcast conversations
with Tyler I try to figure out like
what's the code to what a famous person
has done or achieved and how does it all
hang together and then I talk to them
about it and I know I'm going to be
talking to them about it so I can't just
screw it up like that's the ultimate
test you can't say you know to Martina
Navratilova oh here's what you really
did in tennis and she'll tell you you're
full of it
so that's like an immediate reality test
another method I use for training is
just to keep on writing always be
writing don't care if it never sees the
light of day and write up points of view
that are not your own it's just practice
for thinking writing is thinking if your
writing isn't clear probably your
thinking isn't clear scripts always be
thinking like I'm an athlete I'm like
some version of you know subbing you're
famous athlete what do they do to train
what am i doing to train now and if
they're ahead of you like you know catch
up people don't read enough I think as a
society we're under investing in reading
people feel compelled to finish books
they started that's just a tax on your
reading why would you do that to
yourself imagine a world where any
restaurant you tried you had to keep on
going there you know for days or weeks
you'd hardly ever go out to eat
I'll take reading seriously develop a
passion for it and view it as part of
your practice as a knowledge worker to
get ahead but along the way having fun
doing so
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favourite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include a favorite articles
that I have read and that I've shared
with my close friends for instance and
it's very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that check it out just go to 4-hour
workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll spell
them out and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy
you